[Music]
[Music]
good rancher
it's the miracle life
[Music]
i love you both
and i don't even know you yet
i'm gonna go ahead and hatch these the
rest of the way myself
oh boy you gotta sit down and tender
though
bad rancher
they throw on you for you
after all daddy ranch rachel does for
you
just what you can give me
don't go with the bad rancher go with
the good ranchers 100 american source
steakhouse quality meat subscribe today
at goodranchers.com crowder and lock in
your 25 off every box for the entire
life of your subscription
good ranchers
american meat delivered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
delicious we were just having a debate
here in studio lawnmower man can you
comment below who did lawn mower man who
made it yeah was lawn mower man was that
was that finch was that cronenberg well
i think it was cronenberg but it was it
might have been
might have been finch we'll take that in
chat later on mug club all right
have a lot to get to today here uh
lest we be pulled from youtube i'm just
going to tell you right away mug club
lotto crowder.com mug club right 30
offers students uh active military
veterans
if you enter in that word the promo code
veteran military student we can also
watch us on rumble the free show monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern
because i am not calling people today
i'm not calling you
to want in violence just to be clear
but i am calling you to fight back
i am calling you to protect yourself and
i mean that both
figuratively politically
intellectually and based on what the
left is doing right now
i do mean literally
okay we are at that point when you look
at these calls to action that you see
from not only leftist politicians which
are far more severe than anything donald
trump did
but if you see the actions that are
being carried out we cannot have another
black lives matter riot situation all
i'm saying is i don't want to see office
thousands of officers
officer casualties i don't want to see
dozens of deaths
we don't need this in this country it
doesn't have to go that far
come on do your job to the left and
we'll also be talking today about
clarence thomas why he's a pump i love
him his top five moments throughout
history i know that many of you watching
right now are younger so you may not
remember
how often he has been fighting
the wendigos of the left uh and a very
common argument people have asked us to
debunk is uh this idea that banning
abortion is racist that it'll hurt black
women more because of uh you know mother
mortality rates uh it's it's not true
it's hogwash as it were and i'll explain
to you why uh of course gerald a is with
me the best man better man how are you
sir i'm fine and then dave thank you for
asking quickest man on his feet and he
is with me on tour little credit.com
tour will be in uh houston
on september 17th at the financial
center in sugarland and then charleston
west virginia october 8th
and there are a bunch of dates there you
can see there's phoenix there's
baltimore there's red bank baltimore we
have our flak jackets there's nashville
but a lot of those are are closer to
selling out uh sugarland is very big and
west virginia is very big so okay
doing well there sugarland sounds
delicious it does yeah yeah houston one
of the most obese cities in the country
should be sugar foot yes
um that's hilarious is it really
no
no it is the most i think it's the most
obvious major city in the country and
it's called sugarland it's called sugar
land
yeah that's uh that's bad naming yeah
this is perfect or it's naming yeah
that's true
and uh before we move on here uh we're
going to be talking about clarence
thomas we're going to be talking about
the calls to violence and hopefully you
guys can share this we'll make it
available on social media just a montage
of those on the left using the words
fight you know talking about people need
to fight like hell also that this won't
be one through an election but we'll get
to that but first did you know that
justice clarence thomas is uh actually
a warlock who prac did you know this
perhaps is black magic yeah
y'all are going to hate what i have to
say today clarence because you're
talking man it's always been true and
it's weird that younger people don't
know about it it was part of the anita
hill case he accused anita hill of
putting pubic hair on his can of coke to
influence him his first language was
gullah when we say that the supreme
court has which is warlocks workers on
it
we mean it
this is why when people say hex the
supreme court do this and that hex the
patriarchy do things like that we forget
that there are witches and workers on
both sides what about that chin strap
are you not patriarchal these people are
using it in very negative ways and i
know
now what his wife got going on somebody
would have to tell me but clarence
thomas is a hoodoo man
a who do man
lance thomas is a hoodoo man what are
you
you're wearing a witch's hat yes yes
[Laughter]
z george
that who do that you do so well clarence
do you really want to hurt me yes yeah
stop asking yes
isn't it come on that's black and well i
say i repeat myself androgenous that's
black modern trans boy george without a
sense of humor indeed let's get a side
by side for that a little bit later
that's exactly what that is it's
chappelle and nutty professor yes
it's if chappelle did a boy george
sketch yes
he's a hoodoo man
we're just gonna let that go huh people
yeah he's asking if you want to hurt me
i don't it doesn't make sense
all right that who do that you do that i
do
yes i i just didn't know that was a
thing you remind me of the freak what
freak act like that's a word all right
saying there's witches there and this
has been a constant theme we'll be
talking about clarence thomas i want to
be clear the left didn't try to get rid
of him because he was a black man and
it's overused today the left wanted to
get rid of clarence thomas when he was
being appointed to the supreme court
because he was
a uh he was a very strict originalist he
was a passionate originalist and so they
did use
the trope of the hyper-sexualized black
man it's just like brett kavanaugh
there's nothing new under the sun only
back then
they they had nothing nothing they had
nothing on kavanaugh so they made it up
but what she just said where he accused
anita hill of a pew and a cocaine to
control him he made a joke
he said ah what's this short curly on my
coke can is that a pube
[Applause]
makes me like more anita did you put
this on here verbatim did that think so
you know it's something like that
ah who's who's shorting curry this is my
diet coke candle i don't know i saw you
manscaping in the back now you know you
tripped the bushes make the tree taller
i don't know why he sounds like tracy
i'm gonna be on the supreme court
they've fallen out at the end i want to
be a justice
so yeah roe versus wade i want to make
you all pregnant yeah
i look at you wrong you get pregnant uh
i'll you won't roll my way i wrote your
way first
did i crash my car
i got hit by a walmart truck for the
pregnancy test yeah i judge you till you
love me and it came up positive
let me tell you what my dad saw tracy
morgan live just for last my dad just
went bow
what he goes stop stereotyping yourself
he's like okay
[Laughter]
he's the worst stand-up comedian i've
ever seen in my life all right i love
that you're dead booed keep boo tracing
morgan yeah if my dad heckles he doesn't
do it with he he does it deliberately
and it's he's the kind of guy who will
give you a tough time he'll go all in
too i've watched him heckle cup by just
laughing really hard
oh yeah that's just someone who's like
you're like oh this guy over here
do the one again do the one again how
about how blacks are different than
whites
it just ruins their rhythm
[Laughter]
if the comic's a jerk well of course
he's not just doing it no no no no every
time for kicks it's odd it's every time
a black man is on stage it's weird no no
that was with uh that was with the white
guy actually i'll give you the name
after you'll know who it is i'm sure
yeah i kind of guess yeah you could
probably guess so here let's get to this
uh and i want look have you noticed this
and do you think that there actually is
a scarier threat of violence and call to
action with violence you can comment
below coming from the left compared to
donald trump or is it just a matter of
making them play by their own rules i
think it's a little column a little
column b
so
let me refresh your memory for those who
uh haven't tuned in to
abc nbc cbs cnn at any given minute um
because they run this they have this on
a loop like a morphine drip what
happened back
then
if you remember when uh president trump
told all of his supporters to fight like
hell january 6th
and we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
now keep in mind that is what they
consider to be a call to violence and
we'll get to the articles of impeachment
in a second but before we get to what
they did to him and is what they want to
do to you which we're seeing now with
january 6 that retired couple just had
their home invaded
um
it was at least pretty clear donald
trump went out of his way
to make clear what he was calling people
to do this is what the media doesn't
show you
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
today we will see whether republicans
stand strong for integrity
of our elections but whether or not they
stand strong for our country so two
things there can we all agree it was
pretty clear that he was saying
peacefully well it was just because he
said it yes okay and he said with your
words he didn't say with your fists
right with your break and you know what
else do you know what he also didn't do
even with the figurative call to fight
who is he calling people to fight
republicans his own party he said call
to see if they will be strong out of
luck he didn't say go over there and
fight like hell to the nearest the
nearest trans amoeba you could find
drop a house on them right right i want
to see their stockings curl up from
under the state capitol
and you were there and you and you they
say a lot of people were there
no he said peacefully patriotically make
your voices heard and see if the
republicans will stand up for you he was
calling
his own party to the mat yeah so even if
you want to say it was a call to
violence which it wasn't because you
have ears again all references available
at lydia's credit.com he was very
clearly calling people to hold their own
party accountable not to co commit even
figurative acts of violence against
political opposition in the street i
think it's a very important delineation
so let's look at the articles of
impeachment that were filed against him
because of that
keep in mind this has never been done
before
they impeached a sitting president
twice
twice yes that's for one of them
these were the articles he willfully
made statements that in context
encouraged and foreseeably resulted in
lawless actions at the capitol such as
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore so i
love how they say in context and then
don't provide the context yeah exactly
right they're known for that and by the
way you know what he said for them to do
just
return the electors to the states until
we figure this out that was it he wasn't
saying stall me as dictator he wasn't
saying that joe biden couldn't have
possibly won the election there's no way
in the world he was very adamant that he
thought he won right but he's saying
return it to the states until we sort
this out that was his call yep that's
insurrection that's and this was before
a lot of the bs lawsuits and by the way
we've talked about we've been at the
front of this there was enough with the
changing of the voting laws that
violated the pennsylvania constitution
there was enough with double voting with
ballots that weren't marked properly
there was enough with people who were
voting multiple municipalities that you
didn't have to say it was about dominion
voting machines there was already enough
that it happened at that point this is
before
some people who were grifting got absurd
and made unfounded claims now this guys
the double ballots were marked properly
yes yes yes
they were marked
so they impeached him
they're saying in context disregarding
the context of peacefully and uh they
claimed of course that it was it which
will then later bring us here to what
we're having now but the left claimed
back then it was akin to
incitement sedition this mob was in good
part
president trump's doing
incited by his words
his lies wrong
this violence in good part
looking more
responsible everlasting shame and he
clearly has indicated that over and over
again
and by inciting sedition as he did
yesterday and then yesterday her mask
has made a culmination of attack on our
institutions of democracy
this time the congress itself
inciting a mob to attack the capital
okay you guys make your own judgments
there by the way hey they're in the
control remember uh to pull out that uh
that old muppet heckler sketch that we
uh we have as a recurring thing we never
we never ended up doing that
incorporating it
so more tweets here elizabeth warren
tweeted
donald trump incited an insurrection at
the u.s capitol the house has fulfilled
its constant constitutional duty by
delivering an article of impeachment to
the senate hi yeah hey i don't know why
she
wrote that that's odd she makes a lot of
money off her casino yes she does yeah
she tells the jackpots by the way don't
pay out if it's she's renovating her
apartment that's what i've heard
uh aoc gorgeous totems on the way in
right
aoc made these comments to my gop
colleagues know that this president
incited an insurrection against and
incited his mob to find harm and
possibly kill
not just democrats but you too didn't
mention democrats there by the way he
talked about people holding republicans
accountable he will allow opportunities
of physical harm against you if you
aren't sufficiently loyal to him remove
him wait hold on a second allow allow
opportunities of physical harm against
you do you mean like catch and release
do you mean like violent offenders in
new york and these cities who are just
it's just a revolving door like elf of
rapists
yeah i think that's true do you want to
know who you want to blame for this if
you're pissed off that there weren't
enough police officers national guard
anybody else nancy pelosi would be a
great place to start she had the power
president trump approved her getting
whatever she needed
to defend the capital well she can't do
it blamed for what she didn't do while
she was dead
by the same logic aoc is saying hey he
will incite a mob he didn't inside a mob
we have the context for that if you want
to blame somebody for being in danger
that day
blame the people who didn't have enough
people there to protect you because it
looked like politically they knew
something was going to happen and it
played better for them to let it happen
than to have it by the way you know you
got the k-hole reference and he didn't i
didn't oh of course um
i bet you her biography is going to read
the same as fear and loathing in las
vegas
i i i set my way to dc with uppers
downers laughter screamers
except i bet you her biography will if
it's an autobiography will be about as
legible as stevie wonder's autobiography
i don't know what to do with this she
had doctor writing like that so that's
them saying that donald trump was
calling people to violence you just saw
those clips and that brings us to now
where um it doesn't only look like
they're taking a page out of donald
trump's playbook i would argue and i
want to hear from you
because you can both sides this thing
that it's far worse
this is a sad day for the country in my
view
but it doesn't mean the fight's over the
supreme court does not get the last word
the people do and we are going to fight
back
[Applause]
while republicans seek to punish and
control women democrats will keep
fighting ferociously
to enshrine roe v wade let's fight
into law of the
[Applause]
be out by the land
we will be out by the millions we are
going to make sure we fight by the right
you can't say fight everybody
this is going to have massive impact and
so we are fighting like hell it's going
to take every single thing we've got
it's not going to be solved with an
election it's going to be solved with a
fight of a lifetime
so let's contrast that with let's see if
republicans are strong on election
integrity versus this is not going to be
solved by an election it's going to be
solved by the fight of a lifetime now
granted some of those clips if you take
them and they say uh and something by
the way we mean politically but again if
you look at the rhetoric and you look at
the results and they use the words
literally whitmer fight like hell and
many of them say fight and take to the
streets not peacefully
in single single file fashion
using the buddy system
march over to the capitol building to
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard to your own party they're
saying take to the streets and fight
like hell because they want to legislate
your wombs
hey are any of these people going to be
held accountable any of them going to be
whitmer definitely whitmer has to be
banned from twitter at least right
dorsey at the very least and by the way
that's why you can uh right now we're
wearing these dave has one gerald has
one you can buy the fight like hell
shirts
at crowdershop.com because i don't shy
away from it i have no problem with them
saying fight so long as you allow us to
say fight and right now when i say fight
like hell i mean fight back
there are people with makeshift flame
throwers we showed you yesterday yeah at
the cops
think about thinking every think of this
for a second remember every movie that
we used to see a mobster movie or even
if you go back to breaking bad i was
like you shot a cop you efford [ __ ] you
have any idea the heat that's good now
you have these antifa people flame
throwing police officers
they're worse than the mob yeah i don't
know why cops are still the good guys in
movies
even when i watch them i'm like aren't
you guys the ones you know pushing the
narrative that they're all bad i know
yeah well by the way i have a ques how
is it not trying to destroy democracy by
saying we'll just defy the supreme court
don't you know that that's why it's
there
it's there to solve the problems that
the united states has that can't be
solved any other way that's why you go
through this process to get the final
word on an issue right that's the
supreme court's job if you say defy the
supreme court what's the next step the
natural next step is that you defy the
law in that state and then the supreme
court has a ruling that is the law of
the land and the federal government has
to come in for us how do they come and
enforce that law they tend to come armed
if you're telling people to defy that
because you don't like the ruling not
that it's taking away a second amendment
right or the first amendment right or
changing democracy you just don't like
what they've done
you're calling people to eventually be
violent against that of course they're
only natural of course they are and by
the way aoc her political solution was
executive orders like these people have
too much power they're unelected they're
lifetime appointments so uh executive
order that
hold on a second let me get this
straight roe v wade giving the states
the authority
giving the elected representatives in
each state the authority to create their
own abortion laws by the way you can
have the most radically pro-abortion
laws in california and colorado if you
want that is anti-democracy but having a
president sign an executive order to
supersede the supreme court who is
supposed to be autonomous that is not i
just i'm a little murky on the rules can
maybe you guys can clarify below you can
comment for me because i i i don't know
it's hard for me to follow it's about as
hard for me to follow as aoc's left
eye she seems to have more power than
anybody and i can't figure out why
um sometimes it's just the uh
well sometimes she's stupid whoever
controls the mob has the power yeah
seems to be the truth though right yeah
and we will poison their souls
with stupidity
with aoc my mouth is your punishment
must be more moronic
this is my idiot who deserved this were
you about to say something they're
talking ellen oh yeah i i know we're
talking about clarence thomas and i have
maybe a good setup clip because hillary
clinton uh she went to law school with
him at yale she was on cbs about two
three hours ago and she had some
pretty uh hyperbolic hold on wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
are you going to show i just want you're
going to show us a clip of hillary
clinton yeah
do we have a barf bucket yeah we have
one i just want to make sure i'm
prepared for this it's close because um
you know i get the crawlies yeah you can
projectile too all right everyone ready
are her ankles on camera
[Laughter]
oh no no cankles miss piggy dangling
from a log singing rainbow connection
i can't do it yeah her ankles she should
have the leather she's have her own
leather special just white coffee cans
these both of them connect a string and
just hello hello
[Laughter]
all right so this was hillary clinton on
cbs two hours ago
right now it is 11 53 eastern
two hours ago talking about her time at
yale with clarence thomas
yeah and then 10 53 she gets pretty
hyperbolic about the consequences that
might come from the overturning of
roughy wade sorry i was off by an hour i
was doing uh we're 953 central all right
okay token i think
go
yeah you know people i went to law
school with him
he's been
a person of grievance for as long as
i've known him resentment grievance
anger and he has signaled
in the past
two lower courts two state legislatures
to find cases pass laws
get them up i may not win the first the
second or the third time but we're going
to keep at it so you're saying people
pay attention to yes the people he is
speaking to which are the you know right
wing very conservative judges and
justices and state legislatures
and the thing that uh is well there's so
many things about it that are deeply
distressing you killed the guy but women
are going to die gail women will die
i can't believe her husband is attracted
to other women that's impossible women
will die are you talking about your
private pilots
are you talking about the babies that
were aborted probably somewhere around
no i'm talking about the clinton body
count here look at you taking it
seriously sorry did she sip out of
kathleen turner's drink yeah she talking
about just lane maxwell that she's going
to kill in prison people will die very
soon you mean like your bus boy you mean
like your pilots you mean like your
friends you mean like anyone who's in a
general vicinity of you if you don't
like them a lot of people shoot
themselves in the back running scared
through the woods yes
twice
the average life expectancy for someone
who knows the clintons is in fact 32. if
i double tap myself in the back of the
head right suicide yeah it's just it
gets to the point where being friends
with the clintons is like being in a
final destination sequel it really
the rebar went through his head
it happens all the time never go tanning
and be on the clinton's hit list how do
i get to your cabin hillary just follow
the uh truck of sharpened logs yes
why are they sharpened like pencils i
don't know hey hillary how did huma die
she was getting lasik surgery and uh
i don't know meteorites just go tanning
near a
loose door
ah wood falls and closes it all the time
exactly
you're just had hillary clinton's house
you put like a coffee mug and then it
shorts the electrical outlet a piece of
glass pins you to the wall and then all
the kitchen utensils fall like seriously
it is a hazard to your health to be
friends with that one and i use that
term very loosely but again keep in mind
what they are saying
if the right said this about a black
justice
would be an incredible problem now i'm
not saying that they can't criticize
clarence thomas because they disagree
with his originalist philosophy however
and we're going to take you uh on a trip
down memory lane here
they did use it
as their mode of attack because they
didn't like what he stood for they said
you know what let's use the the the
sexualized promiscuous black guy thing
so this brings us to a segment i'm very
excited i've been a fan for a long time
that clarence thomas is a pimp
i'm just a civil servant
[Music]
i probably should have flipped that but
no i did yeah probably all right yeah
everybody's heard that song so we have
uh top five clarence thomas moments and
uh a lot of you may not remember all of
these i like clarence thomas a lot just
to be clear
the fact that the big outrage was that
he made a joke about a pube on a coke
can mm-hmm yeah
it just makes me i would rather clerk
for him than anyone else it's supposed
to be you know everyone else hold these
hallowed halls look i got somebody's ass
head on my cam
patriarchy yeah it's just patriarchy
talking that's like good he seems like
he has a sense of humor
be fun to work don't you love how they
say he's an angry black man she says you
know he was what was the term she used
there she tried to say he was uh
grievous grievous i don't even know what
she meant okay dickens yeah
when he would walk these hallowed halls
i found myself overwhelmed with a sense
of dread
for he was black you know yes
he darkened the whole way i mean quite
literally when i was working night
shifts i could only see his eyes and
teeth yeah this is hillary belvedere i'm
hillary clinton oh racist
[Laughter]
so i like that about clarence thomas and
i'm sorry i won't go along with the idea
that just because you're a justice you
can't have a sense of humor or that that
is sexual harassment it is not targeted
sexual harassment that being said they
had nothing to go on so they tried to
make a mountain out of that molehill and
of course they incorporated race into it
so let's go here number five and we're
going to go kind of in in in order um
well first let's set this up uh joe
biden and you're you'll see exactly why
i love this clip he was a clueless rube
back then
who uh was good for nothing outside of
doublespeak and making other people
laugh and or say ha
during thomas confirmation
finding out what you mean when you say
that you would apply the natural law
philosophy to the constitution is in my
view
the single most important task of this
committee just want to make sure we all
know how does he have more hair now than
you and i know i don't know
there's a fervent an aggressive school
of thought
that wishes
to see natural law further inform the
constitution than it does now
argued against by the positivists
led by judge borg now again that may be
lost on all the people
you know and i know
what we're talking you know boy someone
may apply and i know boy
like moore
who leads him in a direction that is
quote liberal
you may apply it in a way that leads you
in a direction that's conservative
or you may
like you may argue not apply it at all
but it is a fundamental question that is
going to be almost impossible for
non-lawyers to grasp in an exchange
but you know and i know yeah when was
the last time you practiced law joey
didn't he attain public office in the 20
the 28 years old yeah it's pretty cool
you got to be honest i'm kind of glad
he's losing his mind yeah well the thing
is because now at least it's
unintelligible well he's crazy but back
then you were just he's dumb yeah yeah
really but you know dave and i know you
know you know here boy and i know son
you know he just pulls out a skull you
see these three dimples all right joe no
no no no no no no that's enough it makes
them subservice please now you go out
there clarence and you get me a switch
you ha
now here's the thing that was
nonsensical racist i know it was
nonsensical
and this is when they say he was a
grievous person
[Music]
clarence thomas
i just love he was a happy word the way
he addressed it in this documentary uh
with a smile and it's as perfectly
dismissive as you can ask for
senator biden was very focused on
natural law how did that go who knows i
have no idea what he was talking about
all i know is that he was asking me
these questions about natural law one of
the things you do in hearing
is you have to sit there and look
attentively
at people you know
have no idea what they're talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
a grievous person grievous he could have
just said he's it let me see if i can
get these headphones on i couldn't very
great you have to get your hat back on
jeremy
this segment goes on for a while
it gets worse we're not the first people
to wear headphones with awesome how do i
do how am i supposed to do this i don't
know figure it out
lean it forward lean it forward it'll
it'll work all right all right leaner
four and i'll turn on my turn off like
this
i just
and don't be shy with your horn work
there
yakuza um
that's his nice way of saying he's an
idiot
[Laughter]
he sounded like an idiot
that's why
he's an absolute idiot
and here's the important thing too um
you saw this with kavanaugh there's
nothing new under the sun
this guy really was and it'll bring me
to a point that i want to make i want to
close this segment with that guy there
andrew breitbart just so you know
without clarence thomas you wouldn't
have had andrew breitbart which you
wouldn't have had breitbart inc
it was watching what effectively
amounted to
i'll let clarence describe it but a
public lynching
in the town square
that turned that man conservative
so allowing the left to try and cancel
and commit character assault guess what
there's value in that when they're so
far off the beam so this happened with
clarence thomas early on
and uh that's why i think i've always
really i've read uh read biographies
he's a fascinating character and very
consistent with the law so let's go to
moment number four
and this is something again this is why
they hate him so much you'll notice a
theme people who they really don't like
are people who completely disregard the
elitism so this is that time that
justice clarence thomas
called out the supreme court's elitist
mentality one of the things that that
happens up here
is we tend to be
very heavily
northeastern in our mentality we
were eight of the nine of us
are from ivy league schools
this court doesn't represent all regions
of the country
the we don't
there's a tendency there's an easiness
to sort of stay to be almost cliquish in
that way with law clerks and etc
i like the idea of getting out to be
around
the the real the citizens the other
citizens in the country people who make
it all work the people who put out our
fires the people who build our homes
people who fight our wars i like being
around them i also like the idea that
their kids can come up here and clerk
that that they can be a part of all this
[Music]
[Music]
here's the thing
again that's indica i have to hold this
headphone that's indicative of a guy who
didn't think
that he was too good for the rescuer
that the institution was too important
to be criticized
think about donald trump right he stood
in the way between the elitists and you
that's the same thing with clarence
thomas on that bench
he doesn't care he doesn't care what
hillary clinton says about him
he does not care
a lot of people don't think that
clarence thomas uh be what he is but it
do
he's not bigger than the game which
brings me to another point here i'm
going to take off these glasses for this
almost like ric flair yes
i'm a little more macho man randy savage
with the glasses
let me tell you something brother i'm
gonna make a supreme court decision
that'll make your skin crawl yeah
snap into a slim jim or a tree off a
tampa freeway
um
this brings us to moment number three
okay
and this is uh
clarence thomas's decision uh relatively
recently in new york state rifle and
pistol association versus brynn
uh and he dropped the metaphorical
hammer saying
the constitutional right to bear arms in
public for self-defense is not a
second-class right this is a through
line you'll see look he's saying we are
all citizens of the united states he
just said that there uh it's not there's
a firefighter and there's a policeman or
there's a garbage man and then there's
me a justice
he's saying there's no second class
right it's a writer it's not for all
people that's how it's supposed to work
here
to bear arms in public for self-defense
is not a second class right subject to
an entirely different body of rules than
the other bill of rights
guarantees that is not how the first
amendment works when it comes to
unpopular speech or the free exercise of
religion it is not how the sixth
amendment sixth amendment works when it
comes to a defendant's right to confront
the witnesses against him and it is not
how the second amendment works when it
comes to public carry for self-defense
damn
you kind of left me on a limb there
casey
yakuza i'm so sorry
you're still sorry i'm sorry notorious
pig you can't you can't
play uh
be ready for the next one
i thought he was doing it after cliffs
but hey
no it's an incredibly important comment
that he made there he he left no
ambiguity for people and this is what
pisses people off because they're saying
he can control what a state can do with
the second amendment versus abortion
where they can't control it it's like
now it's a state's right for abortion
but you're controlling as the court what
they can do and he's like no you're
placing unnecessary restrictions on a
right already given specifically by the
constitution and i think really
important is his word it's not a second
class right yeah that is a big
difference between if you look at people
like the sotomayors if now maybe they
don't feel this way but they try and
rule that way where they say well saying
we have armed security and we have but
it's different for us because we're you
know and you're not
and he was saying no no the fireman has
just as much of a right to
defend himself as i do as a supreme
court justice
again it's it's anti-elitism that you
see from justice thomas which by the way
that's not a pimp that's a gay cowboy
hat but it works this brings me to uh
moment number two
and this is just something that i wish
where is it
got my name my last initial on it um
moment number two
is
this is kind of almost a life creed that
you hear from clarence thomas but again
if you if you've read enough of his work
and if you've watched enough interviews
of him you will see that this is
consistent uh consistently how he
expresses himself
where what you do what actions you take
and the decisions that he makes as a
supreme court justice cannot be dictated
by
societal circumstance or by what people
want him to do so this is number two
here he is dropping some words to live
by you know you can be in the middle of
a hurricane
or you can be on a calm day north is
still north
you could be in a thunderstorm north is
still north
people can yell at you north is still
north
it doesn't change fundamental things
and in this business right is still
right
even if you stand by yourself
[Music]
i don't think there's a whole lot more
to say on that one
this brings us to moment number one
and this is a big one for those of you
who are younger watching and you know
what i'd love to see a comment uh below
uh i know a lot of a lot of you what you
watching right now you might be 18
you might be 22 you know the majority of
our viewers
uh and listeners are under the age of
30. so uh you may not be as familiar
with you know what they tried on brett
kavanaugh they tried with
they tried with justice clarence thomas
first only with um uh what they call uh
uh a whiff of racism
mixed in so first off here before we get
to um
i wanna make sure the final clip is
which the final clip is clarence thomas
is that is that c2 or is that clip c
clip c okay so i want to hit the other
one first yep so um
he was accused of sexually harassing not
raping
making unwanted advances making anita
hill uncomfortable in the workplace it's
complete bull crap all references are
available at lightworkscriber.com there
were a lot of accusations made about him
too that he was a regular at a
pornography store a video store where
the timelines couldn't have added up oh
isn't that a trend like we see with
brett kavanaugh because he didn't live
in that area at that time they tried to
make him seem like he was a pervy old
black man you know the evil promiscuous
black man who's going after all the
white women
that was their mode of attack
and um
the lady uh at first who made this
accusation right uh was anonymous and if
the accusations were true thomas would
have known who had made them uh anita
hill admitted to lying at least five
times under oath just to be clear
and even then if you look at the
accusations that were made
they're really not they're really not
that bad even though they're false now
other female colleagues who had worked
with thomas for years many years
rose to his defense
with him at least once a day he never
made an inappropriate advance uttered an
off-color remark or used coarse language
in my presence i was younger and more
politically active than anita hill
i was the first person to bring and
introduce him to a luncheon with thomas
soul and others at the capitol hill club
during the defended by mario he never
made any inappropriate actions towards
me or any other female with whom i saw
him in addition to working with clarence
thomas at the department of education i
shared an office with him for two years
in this building
our desks were a few feet apart
because we worked
with a joker i could hear virtually
every conversation for two years
that clarence thomas had
not once in those two years did i ever
hear clarence thomas make a sexist or
offensive comment
not once no no now to be fair
good lord yakuza to be fair those women
might have what you call a sense of
humor so they didn't say that justice
clarence thomas never made a joke about
a short and curly honest coke can they
say he never made how is that sexist by
the way right yeah it's not
there's nothing s if anything you'd
probably be looking in the direction of
the guys
like if i found a short and curly like a
dave i'm looking in your direction
huh don't manscape in the office fridge
i think we all know it's not me i'm as
smooth as butter he's like a he's like a
hairless mouse it's true it's true so
obviously talking sexually it was
probably somebody's hair from their head
nobody was like
yeah yeah that's a good pickup line is
this your pube yeah who's been naked
around the coke cans again who's this
guy it's lonely i think i need to see
the rest of them yeah
like that's what happened so even then
again he had women lining up lining up
woman after woman saying uh no that's
not true and then of course you had
anita hill who had to say well yeah i
did lie under oath a bunch of times
there was nothing to corroborate there
was an investigation and this is
something it's a longer clip but you may
not know
that this happened and i want to get
into how it affected andrew breitbart
and myself this was very formative for
me this is a very important time in
american history this is the first time
that you saw this publicly with a black
supreme court justice
um
and uh
this had been going on for a long time
it was a circus kind of like brett
kavanaugh yeah right and i i'm not sure
if these are the opening statements that
we have in the clipper the closing
statements but this had been a media
circus throughout
the entire process right once it was
even announced that he was potentially
going to be a pick accusations and he
had had to endure this and clarence
thomas
incredibly articulately
and i think in a very historic way
addressed the false accusations he was
canceled and metoo'd first
senator i would like to start by saying
unequivocally
uncategorically
that i deny each and every single
allegation against me today i think that
this today
is a travesty
i think that it is disgusting
i think that this hearing
should never occur in america i think
something is dreadfully wrong with this
country
when any person any person in this free
country not just me any subjective to
this this is not a closed room
there was an fbi investigation
just like kavanagh this is not
an opportunity
to talk about difficult
matters privately or in a closed
environment
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint
as a black american as far as i'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves to do for themselves
to have different ideas get it and it is
a message
that unless you cow town to an old order
this is what will happen to you
you will be lynched destroyed
caricatured
by a committee of the u.s u.s senate
rather than hung from a tree
[Music]
should have edited the dmx that's he's
fired after this it just felt
appropriate yeah yeah yeah
no i think that was right yeah that's
about right yeah
uh i'm gonna take off this hat now so i
can hear you shut off the speaker but
this is think about what he just said
there the constant through line is
no one
not just me
yeah no one
it wasn't i'm the hope and change
it was no one should go through this it
wasn't hillary clinton when i was at the
school and we were at the
uh you know the ivy league it was no
american should have to endure this
there's no due process no this isn't a
closed room
this is a message to americans
that if they try and achieve better
if they try and for example some people
use the exam use the analogy now go off
the plantation particularly for black
people that they will go after you and
they will ruin your reputation nothing
that any of these black conservatives
saying today is new
and i'm not saying they shouldn't say it
no one's saying it better than clarence
thomas said it yeah
it was the original cancer it was a
combination of canceling
due to opinions
because he was a black man with the
wrong opinions a little bit of me too
mixed in there
and uh a little bit of of fake news yeah
all the above you what do you think was
different about him at yale
yeah i wonder what it was i wonder what
it was i put my finger down oh you mean
that he actually uh deserved to be there
and was you know good oh i mean yeah
unlike
really he had to work for it unlike
barack obama who uh you know was never
published in the harvard review ever the
only only uh editor of the harvard
review not published the harvard journal
sorry well i remember seeing that i'm
sorry you can't make these comments in
any other form and not face legal
consequences like right his point that
he's making the senate can just throw
out i mean when they have these
committee hearings they could just throw
out whatever they want without evidence
this is exactly why johnny depp sued
amber hurd because it had a democracy
impact on his career
imagine if he doesn't get confirmed
imagine if by the way and just remember
this is circa racial jungle joe biden
leading this right just remember who
we're talking to be clear he said i
don't want my kids raised
that's what joe biden said back before
he installed the pipe cleaners yeah so
let's say he's not confirmed what does
he go back to doing now you've been
branded and confirmed a racist by these
people or not a racist i'm sorry a sex
offender by these people somebody who's
not even a sex offender a guy who made a
sex
oriented joke well turning a slight
thing into making you appear to be a sex
offender right
i mean that was really one of the first
times that
you saw
the news become that weapon yeah yeah
and even even let's say he did go to a
porno video store which he didn't no it
wouldn't be relevant right they just
decided what can we bring out that makes
this guy
look bad what can we bring out that he
doesn't here's what it is it's a game of
inches where they just want to make you
quit
yeah right you saw us using amberhead as
an example they just go do you really
want people to think that you have some
penthouse letters you really want that
going public today it would be you
really want your pictures from icloud
going public or do we uh settle this
they just want enough leverage you know
what we might be able to say you went to
a porno store you know what we might be
able to say that you made some advances
at a black woman hey
you also have a pension for white women
we might find some people in college who
say that you hit on them at a party do
you really want how about you step back
that's what we're talking about when we
say fight like hell fight like hell is
plant your feet now don't step back now
clarence thomas has never
never to the best of my knowledge taking
a step back he's the only person i can
say that about yeah and they did this
with kavanagh we didn't do this with
kagan we didn't do this with ginsburg
like that's not how republicans they get
tend to go after your policies the
decisions that you made they bring up
questions about those things but they
don't accuse you of rape or making
inappropriate sexual advances on
employees for saying stuff like that but
here's the here's the they ask you why
you you know smoked crack with a
domestic terrorist in college that kind
of stuff here's the three line for me
january 6 hearings are going on right
now
what they're doing is throwing out
accusations it's more political theater
it is not trying to get to the truth of
a matter right in the kavanaugh
situation in clarence thomas situation
they weren't trying to get to the truth
they were trying to push a narrative
same thing with january 6th that's all
that's going on you can't do that
anywhere else right except in these
committee hearings these committee
hearings you can do it in media and
professors can do it it's professors
fact checkers media and these committee
hearings i think about say something
dave oh uh and this is something i
wanted to to
mention here
without clarence thomas there is no
andrew breitbart so i was one of the
first uh like four contributors before
it was a
breitbart anything it was a big
hollywood breitbart.com because it was a
shooting budget someone else had big
hollywood so that was the original
breitbart place and as a place for
people in hollywood actors directors
producers where they could actually
write
you know whatever they wanted and they
could be conservative and not worry
about having an editor access so in
other words it was like a conservative
version of the huffington post that's
how it started
andrew breitbart wasn't always
conservative and the clarence thomas
hearings and this is why sometimes when
people say well why don't you start
another non-profit well why don't you do
uh just uh you know uh go and go into
schools or create a curriculum because
guess what
seeing
in front seeing as believing and seeing
what was taking place in front of them
with clarence thomas
a young
primarily left leaning i would never say
like to he wasn't like today's
progressives but it primarily left
leaning by default andrew breitbart
watched it unfold
and that was what changed him here's
what he said
it was uh i'll do that andrew it was
impossible for me to not recognize that
clarence thomas being black was part of
the story
how in hell could white americans leahy
biden and metzenbaum let alone former
kkk grand poobah robert byrd and
chappaquiddick's very own ted kennedy so
arrogantly excoriate this man whose
personal narrative from sharecropper's
grandson to supreme court nominee
embodied the american dream i did not
leave the clarence thomas hearings a
republican
he wrote
this was
this was the exact point though i
realized not just that i disagreed with
the democrat democratic party but more
important that the media were its
dominant partner in crime
so just allowing
the left be as the left do
and shining a light on it guess what
we always talk about this with abortion
hey could be the next cure for cancer
hey it could be the neck insert here
could be the next uh
uh churchill could be the next george
washington right we have no idea hey you
know what
right now one of the hundreds of
thousands of people across mug club
across uh youtube right now live this
second let alone the millions once in
this archive one of you
may be the next andrew breitbart
one of you
may be the next clarence thomas
because you see what's happening and all
that is required is the truth to be
contrasted with it and that's what we do
we fight like hell with the truth and
that's what clarence thomas has been
doing for a very
very long time so once this is once the
shine is gone
and nobody else is talking about
clarence thomas first off go back and
see all of the pieces that we've done on
clarence thomas in the past
but i want you to pay attention to him
in the future even if they seem like my
new rulings and you will find something
incredibly consistent you will find that
clarence thomas throughout his entire
career
win lose or draw popular or not has not
made it about him or made it about him
being a more capable justice
he's always made it about look we either
have these rights and freedoms in this
country meaning everybody does or nobody
does and that's why the left has tried
to destroy him and they're trying to do
with everyone now
all these public figures now whether
you're running for governor
or whether you could be the next supreme
court justice they did it to clarence
thomas first this has been based
clarence thomas i'm
[Music]
all right hey by the way uh good
ranchers you saw that uh go with the
good ranchers yeah
good rancher's a better i don't really
know if you want to get not they don't
want to get meat from
the special needs rancher but no but
he's friendly he's very well he knows
how to rant he doesn't know how to ranch
that's the one thing he's just a rancher
savant
he's too good i mean every now and then
he crushes the rabbit well on accident
daily but yeah he's got a lot of rabbits
yeah you gotta eat a lot of rabbits to
go rabbits makeup rabbit ragu
so uh celebrate the fourth of july with
100
american meat right now there's a
limited time deal you get uh two free 18
rib eyes with the promo code crowder and
that's those are the ones that i ate the
most uh the robots these these are not
the robots aren't they what's this
you guys gave me the angus beef they
didn't give me the real rib eyes but uh
that's what i i love the ribeyes
from good ranchers and by the way a lot
of meat that you get in the stores it's
not american it's coming from overseas
and it comes they come from factory
farms good ranchers are better priced in
the grocery store now at this point
especially if you use this promo code
and you actually know that you're
supporting
real farmers so 70 value if you go to uh
is it good uh we have it right down
there goodranchers.com or enter the
promo code crowder two free 18 ounce rib
eyes
they are delicious there's nothing don't
worry there's not meat in that box
there's not no there's not yeah we ate
it okay just a dead rabbit okay yeah the
the guy put it in there it was a little
weird all right
so we can move on from this uh while
we're talking about clarence thomas uh
can i keep the jacket on though it feels
kind of
no it looks good it looks very elephant
johnny yeah exactly i love it no keep it
on
keep it on
i can't do that i can't by the way tiny
dancer those lyrics don't make sense at
all hold me closer tiny dancer
yeah someone the boulevard is not that
bad what yeah well i think it's that bad
well i mean it's not the worst place
that's not the worst place because
someone handing out tickets for jesus i
don't know
it could be
candle in the wind doesn't it change it
for you too when he's singing about how
much he wants to come home to his lady
and you're like yeah
well yeah that was much
yeah that's when he had all the models
at one time right and then he was like
that's enough of that you know they got
bored with women nick depaolo what i
love is he just put he pulls for
reference for like a gay man who people
acted as though he wasn't gay but paul
lin oh yeah and i don't know it was an
actual but he pauline was on hollywood
squares and it was like liberace and
elton john people didn't know that they
were gay back there at least you know
they put the blinders on right yeah but
paul in they asked him something i think
it was hollywood squares like uh this is
what you do what you say when a woman
goes overboard on a ship and paul in and
nick apollo said this is probably a joke
he wrote pauline said full steam ahead
he's so gay we can pull it up on mud
club of paul lin clip because
yeah all he did he always had the ascot
tied sideways right yeah
oh i was always smoking but you're not
you're not married i guess i just
haven't found the right one yeah i don't
know what it is
it's also not legal
right right yes yes
and by any misses yes
well today it would be just as cool they
would do that with liberace yeah they're
like so you're still a bachelor huh
liberace is like yeah well i'm married
to my work and it's a man named work
yeah
it goes by bill
but i call him work work
time to time to play my concerto on the
typewriter
all right let's go to this this is
something you're hearing quite a bit a
few of you have asked me to
rebut this and you can comment below if
this meets
meets your standards because you had
asked for this this is a claim being
made everywhere right now the idea that
banning abortion is racist we dealt with
yesterday how white supremacists would
actually want as many abortions as
possible because black women
commit abortions at a disproportionate
rate because they've been targeted that
way but now they're trying to make this
argument that banning it is racist
because that black women
disproportionately suffer from higher
maternal mortality rates and that'll get
worse if you ban abortions this is a
really lazy argument again this is their
claim right now
and it only requires
two minutes of research to understand
why
we make the references available at a
lot of credit.com especially if you're
in college so you can go check them out
for yourself don't take my word for it
you'll have levar burton when he says
it's like you have to take my word for
it great oh so he's showing us a
six-year-old because you believe he has
more credibility yes well i like this
book and levar burns like see he says
he's not lying he doesn't know anything
[Laughter]
so the claim is that abortions save
lives right because black women have
hired more maternal mortality rates okay
here's uh oh we have a video that's
right here's a video of them making that
claim when you look at the uh
the difference between the women of
color and the
anglo so to say the
disparities in health care alone before
world versus weight was overturned in
the way in which black women and women
of color get treatment when it comes to
health care now this being a whole
another situation well the supreme court
ruling striking down roe v wade could
impact women how george lucas is in i
guess than anyone else a duke university
study estimates that a complete abortion
ban could increase black maternal deaths
by 33 percent 36 million people and this
is a far right extremist supreme court
as making the decisions far-right
extremist blacks
like clarence thomas
lies when black women were
when we know that black women the
leading cause of death before 1973 was
the sepsis
was the sepsis that went along with
these with these unsafe abortions and we
have a black maternal morbidity crisis
here uh black women are three times more
likely to die
um in childbirth and so are they more
likely to play billy zane in the phantom
the phantom 2
here's by the way the truth
maternal mortality actually is higher
among black females it is that is true
yeah that's not that's true
but i love how on the left they go
correlation doesn't equal causation well
the good news is with something like
this you can check this out pretty
quickly you can look and say okay is it
just because there are a bunch of
doctors who secretly are killing black
women and giving them worst care right
or
when it comes to health health is the
easiest sort of
it's one of the easiest areas often as
it relates to diseases and mortality
rates to cross-reference and see where
there's some kind of a similarity or
overlap
so
it's true they do die at higher rates
black women but there are several other
comorbidities that are related
to what they call maternal mortality
rates and that means you know mothers
who die or die during birth okay there
are other factors that contribute
outside of just racism racism racism
let's look at them some of the highest
contributing factors to maternal
mortality
and just how much more highly black
women suffer from them so heart disease
failure that's the number one reason
right for for maternal mortality black
women uh suffer from that at two times
the rate of white women hypertension is
a severe comorbidity a complication with
pregnancy and birth they suffer that at
1.67 times that of white women
hematologic disorders
four times that of white women
four times that of white women then you
can go down the list things like
diabetes there are health issues that
yes affect black women that would
contribute to so for example if you look
at you know a hemologic disorder okay
four times out of white women but the
overall maternal mortality rate is 2.5
that of white women with black women
also by the way why is it three and a
half times out of hispanic women
hispanic women live in poverty here
a lot of hispanic women don't have
access to you know the yale hallway
health insurance whatever it is that
hillary clinton has i have no idea
so heart disease failure double
hypertension almost double uh hemologic
disorders meaning we're talking about
things that would affect the blood four
times out of white diabetes you're
talking about several multiples and by
the way these
tragic of course outcomes are the result
several things first off genetics they
do play a role things like anemia yeah
that's true sickle cell is something
that doesn't affect white people that's
not a huge contributing factor but i'm
just using this as an example to say
that
claiming there's no difference between
races doesn't do anybody any good and
then yeah some poor health choice some
poor health choices yeah so my wife as a
nurse she's worked with patients at
different stages right people who have
to make changes or die or people that
just need to make changes to
maybe make a better yeah
exactly not you dave or make make for
their life a little bit better and she
says this you can't force somebody to
take care of themselves and this is one
of those things that you just don't
factor that in that people are going to
make poor health decisions you can't
just say pull on the heart strings of
people and say black women will die ah
there it's racist we can kind of
shoehorn that in right it's racist for a
black judge to agree
that the state should have the right to
determine what's going to happen right
and the second part is
and people buy it well so many stupid
people out there are just looking for
that angle they're looking for racism to
play a part in everything well they use
it as an excuse for everything people
stupid though they just they're buying
what's being sold to them all the time
which is this constant thing this
constant thing of racism
everything is racist racist right and
it's just being sold to you by the news
constantly well it's just you go
downstream media you go is there any
accountability at some point in other
words the accountability here is with
the media they go black women
uh maternal mortality okay all right why
well because they have all these other
health conditions things like heart
disease things like obesity things like
diabetes things like hypertension
yeah why
because of racism
why would that be
because they uh for a while i would say
food deserts
now people can order their food online
uh it's because uh healthy food is more
expensive that's not true i'm sorry
that's not true i won't hear it that is
not true you can eat very healthily
for inexpensive here in this country
it's not true when i was at my absolute
poorest is when i was at my healthiest
because i had every single meal
measured down to the gram because i
didn't know when my next paycheck was
coming in i didn't have time to eat crap
is it true that it's a lot easier if
you're poor to go to taco bell sure is
that any cheaper
than a bowl of oats with some walnuts or
a glass of milk
or baby food or fruit on no it's not
it's not it's cheaper to get some canned
tuna at home
mix it with i mean eat it plain eat some
start eat some sardines eat some it's
not fun but it's cheaper and you can do
it and by the way we're seeing this with
latino women who are poor they tend to
cook at home more and by the way they
also have weight problems but they don't
have a lot of these other health
problems so you can't say racism if it
doesn't apply to every race that's
non-white because you've also said that
we were racist against
latinos right when we're dealing with
the border issue you've also thought
that we were racist against asians when
we talked about my god covet actually
coming from i think asia and now it's
just well no no discount all them it's
just racist against black people at any
point is there some personal
responsibility if you have all of these
health problems at a disproportional
rate
which leads to maternal mortality
where is there accountability that
doesn't stop at me the white guy or the
white woman or the taxpayer being racist
right and where is this person's video
from five years ago ten years ago three
years ago right because this problem
isn't new
having a higher mortality rate for
mothers in the black community is not a
new thing have you been campaigning
against this for a long time because as
you said thousands of women are going to
die yeah so why weren't you trying to
save them before if you really do care
or if this is just a convenient argument
for you right now and by the way there
are solutions out there um when it comes
to maternal mortality just like i was
talking yesterday i don't believe that
in 2022 no one knows about con
that anybody doesn't know about
contraception i'm sorry i don't care if
you're the poorest white person from the
hills of west virginia or if you are
from uh englewood california i'm sorry i
don't believe that you don't know what a
rubber is i don't believe that you don't
know what contraception is i just don't
buy it i may be wrong
statistically i'm not
just like i don't buy in today that oh
it's a food desert and there's no way
for you to possibly get a food that's
healthy or get some exercise maybe you
can't afford a gym membership you can go
outside you know where i trained when i
lived in simi valley and i was house
sitting the park yeah it was push-ups
and dips and finding a heavy log and
doing squats out in the woods where by
the way i found uh that there were black
widows and then uh i ended up getting
stick legs didn't
it didn't work out
you run though yeah yeah you see one of
them oh it'll help you run more of a
leap yes i had a vertical that you know
i out punted my racial coverage yes i
used to taunt bears yes
something you also can't say is that
people don't have access to education by
googling something or looking online to
write information so when you get
pregnant one of the first things that
you tend to do is to say oh i need to
take care of myself in a little bit
different way than maybe smoking a pack
of parliaments a day i've got to make
some changes in my life it would be cool
it would be cools parliaments
chamberlain's whatever of course you can
go in there
you you can go online and find a lot of
information out on what you need to do
and california i don't normally extol
the virtues of a decision made by people
in california but they got this one
right right now they cut their mortality
rate in half the maternal mortality the
maternal mortality rate was cut in half
primarily by educating people on two
issues preeclampsia and doctors what
they need to do with that nurse is when
somebody comes in my wife and i educated
ourselves on that it's literally a
matter of minutes to save your baby's
life and it can it can it can it's scary
it's very very scary but there's a lot
of things that you can do to help
prevent that and also hemorrhaging what
to do if there's hemorrhaging those two
issues that's all they did was educate
people on that anyway what was the first
one you said because i was preeclampsia
preeclampsia explain that for people who
don't know brake clamps is where the
baby's head actually when they're when
after the mom's water is broken the baby
can come down and actually push on the
cord right and cut off the circulation
to the baby right right and so that can
be that can be a very dangerous
situation literally what we were told so
we were ready and i was ready to do this
and the doctor was
yeah exactly if preeclampsia had
happened the first thing the woman needs
to do and again you can find this in two
minutes google searching this the woman
needs to get on in a vertical head down
position as quickly as possible and if
that still doesn't solve it we got a
fetal heart mate monitor that was i
think 60 bucks just because we were at a
higher risk right yeah and literally and
this sounds gross
if you're having to save your baby's
life because it's not working you
literally put your hand in and push
and you've called an ambulance because
it's it's minutes it's four or five
minutes most likely yeah that you have
to save your child's life but again then
the hemorrhaging by the way the
hemorrhaging goes back to you're far
more likely to hemorrhage if you have
hypertension if you have issues that
relate to or you know if you have anemia
if you have to take good care of
yourself humanological disorders yes
that so you're talking about education
as it revolves uh as it relates
specifically to these instances of
giving birth right but we're also
talking about carrying the baby and what
makes a huge difference if your doctor
is not asking about your diet and
exercise first and giving you
prescriptions you need a new doctor you
need a new doctor that is what needs to
be taught in this country across the
board and then you get into specificity
i'm not saying that those drug that
drugs don't serve a purpose i'm not
saying that some people don't need some
help because like i just said there are
genetic
confounding factors here contributing
factors here
that being said diet and exercise is
still that is the engine the
transmission of the car like you said
california got this right they started
educating people references available at
light of credit.com also while we're
talking about this uh
what matters how about we educate people
regarding
the success of the baby after they're
born no no i don't just mean free stuff
here free school free internet for
everything uh 70 of black children are
born outside of wedlock right now yeah
only 50 of hispanic but it's still
significantly higher than the white
community and that is by the way the
single biggest contributing factor to
poverty to crime to being mentally well
adjusted to having successful
relationships of your own our mommy and
daddy in the house together that is it's
you could dump
18 trillion dollars tomorrow into our
educational system and it would not make
a dent compared to having more dads in
the homes yeah absolutely and that's
about unwanted pregnancies right so if
you're having a child outside of wedlock
a lot of times that increases the
chances that it was an unwanted
experience and we never talk about that
we never talk about what is happening in
communities that we can have an impact
on just by educating people not shaming
not pointing our finger and wagging it
at them and saying we're better than you
that's not what anybody is saying all
we're saying is hey this will go better
for you if you apply these principles
and this little bit of knowledge right
that you have access to and it will
change people's lives you think that's
going to go over well with the fat pride
land whale activists oh of course not
hey you know what uh you know you can
reduce your chance of coronary heart
disease by what by
by losing weight i didn't say it say it
i want to hear you say it finish that
phrase no i'm just a doctor i mean
chopping off a little we stand protest
and block vitamin d from the sun with an
umbrella yes yes i would love to see you
out our teacher arm fat will block out
the sun i can't believe they held an
umbrella right well unbelievable they
more so brace it against you
so every time like a fishing rod out
there in the
deep sea every time you hear these
arguments and you don't hear them also
saying these things that can save
people's lives
they don't care about you right they
want your vote they want you scared they
are not trying to save your life
otherwise they would be preaching this
stuff 24 7 and they're not they want the
opposite they want you dead so they can
get your vote well that's true that's
that's true as well look let's let's
follow the simple logic though they want
to scare the crap out of you yeah let's
they also want your focus
they'll pretend you're alive right they
want your vote twice youtube uh that
would never happen right no
they would never interfere with the
safest and most secure votes of joe
lewis in the 2020 election stared at an
intersection in detroit that voted
[Music]
he didn't
you didn't
even stop by a red box that had 19
ballots dropped off and it didn't happen
really that's not a movie 19 votes and
the best of val kilmer criterion edition
yeah that's an anthology that i need
assault and see well that was underrated
so um i think it is important if we even
just look at let's let's use their
simple stereotype
i'm not saying this is true but they go
the republicans are the party of the
rich now that's not really true anymore
sorry
fantastic i celebrate the uh the uh the
republican party it's the party of the
rich
we now know it's a part of the working
class but it's the party of the rich
they they that's their base okay the
democrats are the party of the poor
let's just use that logic then then if
it were if it's true it's not
wouldn't the republican party
conservative movement
it would require that
you be rich
because they need a base and it would
require the party of the poor
remain poor
now the truth is
the conservative wing is a wing of
optimism it it only works if you
understand the evil that is human nature
but you believe in a better future for
yourself you believe that you can make
it you believe that you can move up
through the social class system where
there is no more uh you know class
mobility than here in the united states
it doesn't really exist in in in europe
or at least it certainly didn't until
the last 50 years you believe that you
can
decide what's best for your family you
believe that you can move in to a better
area and the liberal wing has to deny
the evil nature of humanity that all
people are inherently good that being
said
all people are inherently helpless
you can't get healthier it's because
you're black
you can't get ahead you can't expect to
get 100 cents in the dollar only 77.
it's because you're a woman
well you get you you're being mistreated
because you're lgbtqaip
one
the right
has to acknowledge the evil of humanity
that's the dark side of it you have to
acknowledge that human beings are
inherently selfish and flawed that's why
you cannot be yoked to them but you have
to believe that you can achieve better
for yourself and one has to deny the
evil of humanity so that you can all be
yoked together because who would want to
be yoked with evil so you deny that but
then you also have to remain hopeless
because give me give me government i
need i need you need to see that is the
two different world views and you see it
when we go through all of these stories
whether it's clarence thomas whether
it's roe v wade whether it's black
maternal mortality take your pick that
is the constant through line and you do
have to decide where you line up there
is no fence sitting here because then
you just end up vlad the impaled now
we're going to go to mug club and play
what's in the box which we could never
play uh here on youtube with thomas
finnegan and dave and i
lateralcrater.com tour houston september
17th at the uh smart financial center in
sugarland and uh charleston west
virginia october 8th is the charleston
coliseum these are like five thousand
seats the coliseum virginia looking at
you baby let's get some i said to uh gay
william i was like there's no way
there's no one there west virginia
there's no one there how do he goes
trust me
there's some people and now he's like
look told you and it started filling up
quickly i was like oh man i didn't
realize that there was anyone there i
only watched that episode of wild boys
and i thought it was a bunch of guys
with bottles of wild turkey and atvs so
hey you know what color my face red uh
youtube piss off
you